اغلقت عائلات الاسرى الاسرائيليين
المحتجزين في غزه الشارع الرئيسي المؤدي
الى وزاره الدفاع في تل ابيب رافعين لافته
ضخمه تطالب بابرام صفقه تبادل اسرى تتزامن
تلك المظاهرات مع اجتماع اعضاء مجلس الحرب
لمناقشه شروط حركه حماس بخصوص الصفقه من
جانب اخر تظاهر مئات الاسرائيليين
اليمينيين بالقرب من محكمه العدل العليا
في مدينه القدس من اجل الضغط على الحكومه
الاسرائيليه لمواصله الحرب على غزه وتحقيق
اهداف الحرب التي اعلنتها
الحكومه معنا من ام الفحم الدكتور مهند
مصطفى الخبير في الشؤون الاسرائيليه مرحبا
بك دكتور مهند بينما نتحدث الكابينه كابنه
الحرب يعقد اجتماعه ما التوجه باعتقادك في
ما يخص التعامل مع رد حركه حماس ومقترح
التهدئه عموما بعد الاشارات السلبيه التي
صدرت عن عن نتنياهو
بالامس نعم اعتقد انه مجلس الحرب النقاش
فيه سيكون مختلف عن النقاش لاحقا في
الكابينت في المجلس الوزاري المصغر في
مجلس الحرب هنالك راح يكون جانس موجود
وجادا ايزنكوت اعتقد انهما يعني ينطلقان
من ان ملف الاصره والرهائن هو اولويه اولى
في هذه الحرب وان اسرائيل يجب ان تتقدم في
هذا الملف وانهاء هذا الملف بالذهاب الى
صفقه تهدئه وانا اعتقد ان انه النقد
الشديد الذي وجهه جانس في الايام الاخيره
لبنيامين نتنياهو كان نابعا من ان نتنياهو
اعلن بشكل مصبق وبشكل فردي عن موقف شخصي
الذي يعبر وكانه عن موقف اسرائيل من هذه
الصفقه من هذه التهدئه قبل اي نقاش معمق
داخلي في داخل مجلس الحرب نتنياهو يعني في
في الايام الاخيره يحاول ان يعطي اشارات
انه يعارض هذه الصفقه في المقابل نارا
جانس في تصريحاته الاخيره في الايام
الاخيره يعطي مؤشرات متناقضه بشكل كامل عن
بنيامين نتنياهو ولذلك النقاش في مجلس
الحرب هو نقاش سيكون اكثر عميقا واكثر
مؤثرا على النقاش اللاحق في المجلس
الوزاري المصغر الذي اعتقد ان الاراء فيه
هي محسومه لرفض هذه الصفقه وهذه التهدئه
ولكن هل سيكون هذا دكتور مهند رفضا كاملا
بمعنى يلتزم بما قاله بالامس نتنياهو ان
هذه الحرب ستستمر حتى تحقيق النصر الك
بحسب تعبيره ام انه ربما س
نتوقع ربما نتوقع ان يتم
طرح رد بديل او افكار الافكار
الاسرائيليه في هذه في اطار البحث عن
التهدئه لا لا شك انه التوجه في اسرائيل
هو نحو اقتراح وكانه تحفظات وشروط على
المقترح واعطاء الرؤيه الاسرائليه لهذا
المقترح الرؤيه الاسرائليه ستكون مبنيه
على عده نقاط اساسيه اولا هو ان التهدئه
لا يجب ان تنتهي بوقف اطلاق النار وان
اطلاق النار يجب ان يستمر بين مرحله
ومرحله اخرى من التهدئه وان اسرائيل لن
تفرج عن هذا العدد الكبير من الاصر
الفلسطينيين بمعنى ان اسرائيل لم تقول على
المستوى الدولي انها ترفض وانها ليس لديها
اي اقتراح هي سوف تقدم اقتراحات معينه هذه
الاقتراحات لن تكون مقبوله على على حركه
حماس انا اعتقد ان النقاش في يعني يعني في
داخل اسرائيل الان هو هو نقاش بين يعني
توجهين بين التوجه الذي يضع ملف الاسر
كاولو وبين التوجه الذي الان نتنياهو الان
يتحدث عن مصطلح جديد يسميه الانتصار
الصاحق هذا مصطلح ظهر في الايام الاخيره
وهو يهدف الى افشال الصفقه نتنياهو لديه
نيه بافشال الصفقه المظاهره اليوم في
القدس الداعمه لبنيامين نتنياهو وتوجهه
هذه مظاهرات يعني بنيامين نتنياهو
يستعملها دائما دائما يستعمل جمهوره من
اجل ان ينظم مظاهرات داعمه له لكي يقول
للمجتمع الاسرائيلي ان ان المجتمع منقسم
حول هذه المساله ليس كل المجتمع مع وقف
اطلاق النار و بينما هناك في فئات في داخل
المجتمع الاسرائيلي يعني تدفعني من اجل
الاستمرار بهذه الحرب ولذلك النقاش في
يعني في داخل اسرائيلي الان محتدم اعتقادي
ان نقاش مجلس الحرب سيكون
يعني يعني عميق جدا و وراينا ربما هذا
الانقسام الذي تتحدث عنه دكتور مهند يتجلى
في التظاهرات في الشارع بعضها لعائلات
الاسرى الذين يريدون وقفا او يريدون
الذهاب نحو صفقه تبادل بينما هناك ايضا من
اليمين من يتظاهر من اليمين يريد استمرار
هذه الحرب ولكن السؤال الان عن كيف يجدر
مراقبه الموقف الامريكي وانعكاسه على ما
سيحدث في اسرائيل بلينكن بالامس يقول ما
زال هناك امكانيه للاتفاق
واليوم المسؤولون الامريكيون يقولون انهم
لن يدعموا اي عمليه عسكريه في رفح يعني
هذا صحيح هذا واحد من المؤشرات هذا
التصريح الامريكي هو مؤشر جديد للاداره
الامريكيه تجاه اسرائيل ان ان على اسرائيل
ان تقبل بهذه التهدئه وهذه الصفقه
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه تريد هذه
التهدئه هي تضغط على اسرائيل في هذا الصدد
ولكن بالامس نتنياهو وجه صفعه كبيره جدا
للاداره الامريكيه في في بيانه الصحفي
الذي عمليا خالف كل التصور الامريكي بكل
مركباته فيما يتعلق ايه بهذا الشان وحتى
فيما يتعلق بالتصور السياسي الامريكي
لليوم التالي للحرب بمعنى ان نتنياهو ذاهب
بحاله صدام مع الاداره الامريكيه والاعلان
عن عن عمليه محتمله في مدينه رفح هذا ايضا
اصطدام مع الاداره الامريكيه نتنياهو في
الفتره الاخيره يستعمل كمان يعني خطاب
يحاول من خلاله ان
يسوك سياساته يقول ان الانتصار يحتاج الى
اشهر وليس الى سنوات هذا الامر يحاول ان
يعطي شرعيه له من اجل اجل الاستمرار
بالحرب وكان الحرب سوف تستمر شهرين وتنتهي
وبهذا يحقق الهدف بالقضاء على حه حماس
واسترجاع الاصور الرهائن طبعا هذا الامر
غير ممكن لن ينطلي على فئات من المجتمع
الاسرائيلي ولا على الاداره الامريكيه
التي اعطت اسرائيل مده طويله جدا من اجل
من اجل ان تحقق اهدافها وقد وقد فشلت في
ذلك الاداره الامريكيه معنيه بهذه الصفقه
هي تمارس ضغط كبير على على اسرائيل من اجل
القبول بهذه الصفقه ليس لانها تريد مصلحه
حركه حماس وانما لان الاداره الامريكيه
تريد ان تبني تصور سياسي لليوم التالي
ينسجم مع المصالح الامريكيه ولا تعتقد ان
اسرائيل هي العقبه الاساسيه الان امام ذلك